hey leute was geht ab und jetzt bekommen
beim 1 ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut und zwar steht heute ein echt cooles
video an vor allem für mich selber ich
bin sehr gespannt es wird ein redaktions
video ihr habt sie wahrscheinlich schon
gelesen und zwar weil man also die
loches bringen ja dieses jahr ihr neues
album raus und die erste single kommt
halt genau heute also ich drehe dieses
video auch wirklich am freitag also
jetzt gerade bevor ich sehe ich habe das
kommt auf 17 15 und 30 online die erste
single nennt sich lava und ja die beiden
haben wir das musikvideo schon folge
schickt also ich habe es jetzt schon
ich hab's dir war ungelogen meistens ist
es so wenn ich irgendwo darauf reagiere
dann schaue ich wenigstens vorher mal
rein
ich habe hier jetzt allerdings bewusst
gesagt er kommen du schaust nicht rein
weil ich finde es ist voll natürlich
oder soja so natürlich wie möglich sagen
die reaktion und die erste meinung ich
kenne die beiden jetzt auch schon mega
lange und habe eigentlich so diesen
musikalischen wandel oder den
musikalischen verlauf von damals wo sie
halt auch seinen parodien gemacht haben
bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt letztes jahr
kam er das letzte album von denen
eigentlich ziemlich gut mit erlebt also
ich bin da eigentlich echt gut drin und
kennen die meisten songs auch und
deswegen bin ich heute umso mehr
gespannt zumal sich auch gesagt haben
dass ein mit echt richtig geil und noch
mal was ganz cooles neue jahr ich würde
sagen die ladung gar nicht lange und
fangen sofort mal an so leute ich bin
hätte ich mir ein bisschen mehr hier
das könnt ihr mich besser sehen häufig
so weit ich würde sagen wir fangen an
man muss allerdings auch sagen ich bin
natürlich auch kein musik genie kann was
das musikalische angeht jetzt nicht
genau ins detail gehen ich kann einfach
nur meine persönliche subjektive meinung
dazu äußern und das machbar
[Musik]
also das musikvideo dazu wurde ja glaube
ich in thailand gedreht eigentlich würde
ich auch gar nicht so auf stopp machen
ich meine das nervt wahrscheinlich die
meisten von euch noch ich muss sagen ich
glaube das musikvideo wird auf jeden
fall hat sie zumindest schon so aus und
der anfang war gerade mehr in so
richtungen rap oder so ein bisschen auf
seinem trip beat also wir schauen
einfach mal weiter
[Musik]
der boden ist laura diesen titel vom
also halt lava ist mir schon länger
bekannt allerdings der boden islam
überhaupt das jetzt auf dieses spiel
angelehnt ist weiß ich nicht
[Musik]
von gestern nach zehn schweren tagen gab
gläubigen gab das land also was ich
sagen muss
normalerweise ist man von den beiden ja
mehr so gesang gewohnt also an sich ist
es natürlich gerade auch gesagt
allerdings wird so vom bieten und
vielleicht auch ein ganz bisschen von
der stimme auch so eine leichte rap
schiene gefahren was aber eigentlich
gefällt ich muss auch dazu sagen ich
finde das lied ist so ein bisschen wie
die s18 von denen also vielleicht mal
kurz aus und hiervon
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht verstehen was ich meine
aber einmal halt so vom beat in die in
die gleiche richtung nur dieses lied hat
mir nicht wirklich so gut gefallen und
dann muss jetzt sagen hier bei lava ist
der beat halt wirklich geil und das
passt so zusammen folge hat man bei 6
100 sekunden sowie höheren der zweite
große augen magen gab ist eine große
augen regeln
keinen luftfahrt macht was lustiger asma
zuckerschock szenen nicht das ganze dorf
disco ein fall für den landtag
ist der boden sieht das gesetz
da alles liest ist
alles gehen nicht ein bis wir sonne
dieser biete
also das video ist wirklich richtig geil
so ich und das trading ich bin auch
mittlerweile so ein fan geworden gerne
mal so projekte zu machen wo man halt
auch selber das trading hat keine ahnung
auf das video das rauscht so ein
bisschen leicht ich finde das passt
richtig zum beat und zum gesang
[Musik]
essen
also wenn man sich jetzt den refrain
anhört finde ich dass es zum vergleich
zwilling das feuer das album von letztem
jahr oder vorletzten jahr ich finde es
ist auf jeden fall noch mal eine
steigerung und das hört sich noch mal um
längen finde ich erwachsener von der
musik her wie das klingt also das ist
meiner meinung nach nicht mal so wie bei
dem zwilling allem wo man bei den
meisten songs sagen konnte okay das wird
jetzt wahrscheinlich eher so die
jüngeren hier bei dem song würde ich
jetzt sagen das können sich auch ältere
leute anhören also bei dem zwilling
album hatte ich so zwei drei songs die
ich gut fand ich mir auch selber gerne
mal angehört haben und hier aus dem
neuen album haben wir jetzt ein zungen
der mir auch schon recht gut gefällt
also ich bin positiv überrascht dass ja
schon mal gut
[Musik]
sie haben denn der boden ist aber jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt ob er rappt oder
singt tinnitus hier meine morning
nachtigall
aber das ist mir heute nach dem bisher
sozial ist so anders ist kein abi ball
so ist auf jeden fall ähnlich wie bei
oma ich finde man kann jetzt gar nicht
das ist meiner meinung nach eine
mischung aus rap und gesang aber es
passt gut und das passt auf jeden fall
gut zu beats auf dermaßen erzählt das
ist richtig geil vornehmlich farbe in
grün
doch ich bitte auf b auf klassenfahrt
made in der menge wasser massa und party
ich nehme das land habe bat ich frage
mich wie viele leute da mitgewirkt haben
ein musikvideo welches schon so viele
verschiedene gesichter gesehen es ist
auf jeden fall brutal aufwendig
produziert das hört man und das
musikvideo das kickt richtig rein
[Musik]
wenig heimiswil sonne
dieses monster
normalerweise ist es bei mir immer so
dass ich bevor ich sagen kann ok den
song fire ich auf dauer muss sich dann
erst einmal zwei mal gehört habe auch
das ist so dass wir im ersten mal sagen
feiere ich nicht und mir dann aber beim
zweit oder dritt mal hören aufhält finde
ich doch ganz cool und irgendwann wird
von einer meiner lieblingssongs hier
muss ich jetzt sagen ich bin eigentlich
recht nicht der fan von so einer
richtung aber irgendwie gefällt mir und
was ich auch ganz wichtig finde zu sagen
es grenzt noch mal so richtig ab also
man merkt den unterschied weil die
beiden sind ja auch mal als youtuber
gestartet zwischen youtube musiker und
halt wirklich musik also das ist
wirklich ein fettes ding fettes
musikvideo hat sich geil an
ja ich würde sagen wir haben es einfach
zu ende und
[Musik]
dieser bietet
goslar
[Musik]
der boden ist
also ich bin wirklich gespannt wie das
ankommt bei den ganzen zuschauer weil es
wie schon am anfang gesagt finde ich was
überraschendes ist das der erste song
direkt so in diese richtung geht also
das musikvideo von denen ist online
gegangen geht auf jeden fall mal rüber
schaut euch an lasten daumen nach oben
da und schreibt gerne in die kommentare
schöne grüße auch von alex dem gefällt
[Musik]
da kommt die pommes auf ihn zugeflogen
so das war's video geht drei minuten 10
ungefähr also wirklich war
dazu ist normalerweise feiere ich diese
musikrichtung nicht so allerdings hat es
mich überzeugt und ich finde es echt ein
heftiges dingen dass mich auf jeden fall
gespannt warten ist wie sich der rest
vom album anhört ihr könnt gerne eure
meinung dazu in die kommentare schreiben
feiert ihr ist oder eher nicht so ihr
könnt euch das musikvideo von den beiden
auf jeden fall auch ein genie von den
anschauen ist oben in der video verlinkt
und ich habe auch mal wenn irgendwie
bock hat sich das vorzubestellen die
längst dazu in die video beschreibung
gepackt check das gerne mal ab und ja
wir sehen uns dann wahrscheinlich
sonntag wieder die heute haut rein